creative marketing plans for restaurants
so I got a tweet from one of my
followers love you guys who wrote in to
say how can I make a creative marketing
plan for a healthy food restaurant and I
was thinking you know most restaurants
saket marketing most restaurants are
just average they're mediocre right what
is great about most restaurants there's
not a lot which gives you a huge
opportunity to do something special
something great and I was thinking to
myself what's a good story that I could
tell about a restaurant that I love a
restaurant that I'm loyal to that I go
to every week that I say you have to go
here and I got nothing there was no
restaurant that I absolutely love and
that's kind of sad that that kind of
speaks to how mediocre the restaurant
business is the problem is they're just
selling their products and this is the
same thing with your company that you're
just selling your products you're not
standing for anything important I do
have a story to share though this is a
good one I was talking to a restaurant
that sells burgers it's a burger joint I
actually like their burgers they're good
burgers I'm not loyal to them but if I'm
in the area I'll go eat the burgers are
really tasty and their marketing manager
comes to me says how do we how do we
reach more people how do we get out
there more this similar problem how do I
get more customers through my marketing
and I told them well an idea that I
would do is I would make my restaurant
all about entrepreneurs if you're
talking to me you're going to get
entrepreneur advice that's just the way
it goes I would support entrepreneurs
that have an entrepreneur the week and
feature them in the store I would do
video interviews promoting entrepreneurs
I would have people like me come in as
experts and help entrepreneurs in the
store get people in the store in the
restaurant who are entrepreneurs and the
entrepreneurs will help spread that
right how do you want people to come
into your store if if you we're talking
to me and you said this restaurant is
all about entrepreneurs and helping them
and we have great hamburgers I would go
and I would tell people and I would
bring people say we have to go here and
we'll go regularly
loyal because I like what they stand for
and the market manager comes to music
well that's it just an idea but we don't
support entrepreneurs we just sell
hamburgers and that's the problem right
there that's the problem with every
restaurant and upon with most businesses
you just sell whatever product or
service you have that's not the business
you need to be in you need to stand for
something important and build a
community because if you don't if you
just sell hamburgers or if you just sell
cars or you just sell pillows or just
sell chairs whatever it is you just sell
then you're not going to get loyalty why
should people come to you as soon as
there's a better hamburger or cheaper
hamburger or different hamburger I'm
going to go to that other restaurant I'm
not coming back to you you need to have
a great product ok I hope you are all
selling great products and services but
you need to stand for something on top
of that something powerful that will
make people want to spread the word
about you that's your creative marketing
plan and it doesn't have to be about
entrepreneurs ok that's how I see the
world I want everybody to be supportive
entrepreneurs that's in my DNA if I was
doing a restaurant to be about helping
entrepreneurs so that's fine it doesn't
have to be about I turn to pick
something pick something that you
believe in our community that you want
to support and showcase them and be
their friend and be their cheerleader
and they'll come and support you and
bring their friends and bring their
community with you that's how you build
a creative marketing plan stop being a
mediocre restaurant and a mediocre
business stand for something important
believe for those you watching like the
video thumbs up below let me know you
think leave a comment underneath ask a
question I'll make a video response and
if you want to see more videos like this
subscribe to the channel click on my
face thank you so much and I'll see you
soon
you